je rappelle qu'on appelle le président
pour la valise rtl oui bonsoir président
comment certains présidents ça va très
bien
cette joyeuse année
joyeux anniversaire
joyal et vert
et je voulais je voulais vous souhaiter
bon anniversaire parce que vous nous
aviez souhaité bon anniversaire sur
notre millième dont j'ai joué oui c'est
vrai contre je vais vous dire je viens
c'est mal oui cette volonté d'une heure
je voulais le premier président oui je
voulais savoir juste président quel est
votre taille en table de ping-pong parce
que je voulais vous dire ça je vous en
ferai une table de big bang vous allez
vous entraîner et président je sais que
vous jouez bien au tennis
j'espère qu'un jour on aura l'occasion
de s'affronter tous les deux ce serait
mon cadeau d'anniversaire au tennis oui
je sais vous jouez bien si on pousse à
brad soit un bon anniversaire
oui c'est ça mais là oui j'espère
qu'elles n'ont pas attrapé froid je peux
vous dire c'est marilyn à moi c'est bien
c'est avec mon anniversaire
eh ben vous avez bien raison c'est
brigitte bah oui et donc vous laissez
lui pour moi et j'espère qu'elles n'ont
pas trop et le froid dans un paris plus
vieux noms à léon 12 ans - on vous
embrasse il faut que j'aie que je
n'oublie pas en tout cas ce vous rendez
vous pendant la campagne
xavier votre anniversaire et permettez
moi simplement de passer un message
d'amitié à la fois votre équipe et puis
à tout votre public parce que je sais
que la voulait la jeunesse vous suit et
vous regarde
merci merci
si nous guette la laci merci au revoir
et bon travail vous à moi c'est ma
l'adversaire merci ma cousine
on dénombra merci ses doigts franchement
les mecs là voilà et les chéris le
président est quand même d'être quand
même le seul à faire ça comme s il est
là les mecs et ben on a eu le président
pour lui souhaiter
encore
c'est moi
oh
les
il